good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is scp-1609 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures scp-1609 is contained at
storage site 8 due to the difficulty of
transporting it from that location
scp-1609 is to be contained in a
specially designed enclosure at that
site within a flowerbed
in which a range of aesthetically
pleasing flowers and plants are to be
cultivated it is to be used as mulch
within this flowerbed the flowerbed is
to be tended regularly and all visitors
to the enclosure must remark on the
beauty of the flower bed with particular
emphasis on the quality of the mulch
scp-1609 is to be removed from the
flowerbed at regular intervals so that
it can be treated with wood metal and
fabric preservatives personnel are to
announce their intentions in the
presence of scp-1609 before attempting
to remove it for this purpose personnel
assigned to scp-1609 are required to
wear plain clothes in order to prevent
accidentally triggering a violent
response from a CP 1609 no items with
motors are allowed within a 200 meter
radius of scp-1609 s containment area no
personnel either presently or previously
affiliated with a global occult
coalition nor material referencing them
are to be allowed within storage site 8
in the event of a violent reaction from
a CP 1609 all personnel are to exit the
immediate vicinity and a message is to
be played over the site's interior
speakers informing site staff of the
event
Jude scp-1609 be sighted outside of its
containment area following a violent
reaction staff are to act in a
submissive non-threatening manner formal
clothing such as jackets lab coats
protective clothing jumpsuits and
particularly body armor are to be
removed if possible in the case of such
an event and any weapons capable of
damaging scp-1609 are to be immediately
discarded staff are to ask scp-1609 to
return to containment without attempting
to threaten or command it should
scp-1609 exit storage site eight agents
are to be immediately dispatched in
order to scan the surrounding area for a
CP 1609 and if possible retrieve it at
present there exists no way to totally
prevent scp-1609 from breaching
containment during containment
procedures Center on encouraging
scp-1609 to remain within its
containment area description scp-1609 is
at the present time a pile of splinters
wood chippings
furniture nails and scraps of bleached
leather and fabric weighing in
approximately kilograms the wooden
portions of scp-1609 are made of oak and
the nails are made of steel scp-1609 is
capable of teleportation being capable
of moving its entire mass
instantaneously between two points
without any known limit scp-1609 usually
uses this to bring its constituent parts
together when parts of scp-1609 have
been removed from the mass but scp-1609
can teleport its entire mass at once on
at least one occasion at a distance of
kilometers
scp-1609 is capable of splitting its
mass though it does this rarely any
amount of material removed from scp-1609
s mass continues to display as CP 1609 s
properties scp-1609 has resisted all
attempts to remove it from the confines
of storage site 8 teleporting back to
the site of its own accord
however it has previously teleported out
of storage side 8 for brief periods
before an attorney although this is only
happened on occasion since its arrival
in foundation custody scp-1609 appears
to be in some way sentient as research
indicates it is able to perceive its
environment in a manner that is
currently Pearlie understood and is able
to react to stimuli in an intelligent
fashion details of scp-1609 s behavior
are poorly understood although it has
been ascertained that I will react in
self-preservation and will react
aggressively to certain stimuli which it
connects with a threat to its existence
aside from this scp-1609 appears to
prefer situations in which it is
utilized by humans and will actively
seek out situations where it can be put
to use if it is left idle this is the
reason for the Foundation's present use
of scp-1609 as mulch as this prevents
scp-1609 from becoming idle and
attempting to leave storage site 8 it is
theorized that scp-1609 is capable of
understanding human speech or thought
although this cannot be determined as it
does not comply with tests designed to
gauge its awareness of such stimuli
when exposed to a number of specific
stimuli scp-1609 will react violently
during a typical violent reaction from
scp-1609 it will teleport a portion of
its mass inside the lungs of nearby
personnel causing immediate and severe
lacerations to the interior of the lungs
as well as pulmonary obstruction which
rapidly leads to the victims death
stimuli which can instigate a violent
reaction from scp-1609 include personnel
wearing the uniform or clothes similar
to the uniform of personnel affiliated
with the global occult coalition
utterance of words or phrases used
heavily or exclusively by GOC operatives
such as threat entity while in contact
with scp-1609 any action demonstrating
hostility towards scp-1609 and the sound
of a running motor violent responses
from scp-1609 are rare only such events
have occurred since containment and
scp-1609 quickly reverts to a passive
state after such a response if it does
not continue to feel threatened scp-1609
arrived in foundation custody on after
teleporting to an unused containment
cell at storage site 8 in its current
state careful investigation has revealed
that scp-1609 and was originally a large
chair made of varnished oak and bleached
leather carved in the form of a
reclining woman in a restful state
scp-1609 appears to have possessed its
anomalous properties in this state
albeit with certain limitations namely
that the object would only teleport when
a person within a certain radius
currently unknown felt the need to sit
down or rest without a comfortable seat
or chair nearby at this point scp-1609
would teleport to them and remain in
place until another person had
experienced a similar urge on
both foundation operatives and members
of the global occult coalition were made
aware of the existence of scp-1609 which
was given the temporary designation of
e6000 to the hard to contain nature of
scp-1609 and the possibility of its
existence causing a breach of secrecy
regarding the existence of supernatural
phenomena a small-scale effort to
contain a CP 1609 was launched by GOC
forces it is presently unknown how
exactly GOC operatives captured a CP
1609 but it is known that they succeeded
in reducing the object into its current
form using a wood chipper further
attempts to destroy scp-1609 failed due
to its properties and ability to
teleport away from sources of danger
following this event several members of
the global occult coalition died under
unusual circumstances investigation
through both official channels and
embedded foundation agents within the
GLC has potentially linked scp-1609 to
at least three deaths of personnel
within the coalition although the true
number of casualties amassed due to
their mishandling of the item is unknown
scp-1609 then arrived in foundation
custody it is unknown how scp-1609 was
aware of the existence of the foundation
although it is theorized that it entered
foundation custody due to a low risk of
further damage to itself
the following is document 1609 - one
this is an audio log from dr. Siebert
discussing scp-1609 and the global
occult coalition playing now scp-1609
represents a perfect example of the
flaws inherent in the operating
procedure of the GOC and serves as a
cautionary tale for any members of the
foundation who disagree with our
practices on containing dangerous
objects prior to the coalition getting
their hands on this
it was perfectly harmless a chair which
teleports to you when you need a seat is
normal compared to most of the stuff
that we deal with on a regular basis
when they put it through a wood chipper
it got hurt
scared so by trying to quote protect the
world by destroying it they
inadvertently made the situation a whole
lot worse scp-1609 went from being
harmless to deadly in the space of a few
minutes because of the GOC and we had to
clean up the mess
thankfully scp-1609 is pretty simple for
us to deal with so long as we don't do
anything stupid around it it won't fight
back and it won't try to leave even if
it does it usually comes back I think
I've worked out why it came to us
because it was afraid of the people who
had hunted that's why it always comes
back
it's afraid of the rest of the world now
and it's looking to us for protection
this is why we have special containment
procedures instead of special
destruction procedures
if you break something it's broken
forever when you try to destroy an
anomaly you can't take back your
mistakes that's what a CP 1609 has to
tell us this is why we're right and the
GOC is wrong people and I think we can
all agree with dr. Seaver on that one on
that note this concludes our lecture
thank you very much for listening and
you were all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette Desmond Hoskins and
Gaza berry thank you all very much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
[Music]
you